from nbc sports boston is none other
than tom curran how are you sir
i'm rich i'm good i'm good
love to get to the bottom of this or at
least get something on the record there
not getting any closer well i mean
excellent um excellent attempt and foray
tom um but your your initial question um
was an interesting way to uh
shroud the the ultimate i think if you
drill down what you were saying
my ass the question that you were you
were you were essentially dressing up
yeah okay uh bill wasn't it you and your
crappy roster the reason why tom wanted
out
and your offer of a contract that you
knew that he would rebuff
in 2019 in the summer
until he finally threw up his hands and
said i'm going to be out of here
those two things together yes
i mean the option was
he weighed his options his options were
hey
do you want this half-eaten candy bar
but i mean this is how bill is really
framing it yeah he looked at his options
and decided to go elsewhere what was the
option the patriots were offering him he
had said i want the full candy bar and i
want to enjoy it for a couple years i
wanted to be a yummy one
so is that a happy here's a half eaten
candy bar you can eat for a year now i
was being facetious um but the general
sense of things was that there was no
way to bridge the gap was there any way
possibly to bridge the gap because where
it was okay
in the 2019 offseason
brady
and his folks expected a two-year 50
million dollar guaranteed contract
identical to drew breezes
that's what they had discussed that's
what they expected and then
come august when it still hadn't
germinated and they finally said you're
not going to get that here's a
two-year deal second year is not
guaranteed it's basically an eight
million dollar bump how do you like that
they could have still been here through
2020 if they gave him that bruised
debris deal
and once they didn't do that
the season played out and when brady sat
down with belichick prior to free agency
kind of more doing a solid for the
patriots because he said he would
and belichick said to him look highest
we can go on the capitol he's going to
be 22 and a half million dollars this
year that's it that's all we can do
now we still don't talk of a guaranteed
second year
so yeah there was a gap to be bridged
and there was willingness on brady's
part all the way up until the summer of
2019 to do it
patriots didn't want to believe that
brady could do what he's been doing you
can't blame him for that because no
one's ever done it
when the guy's sitting in front of 20
years
and you still don't believe what you're
looking at
then it's on you when it goes someplace
else
but i guess when it all comes down to it
as well i mean if you are taking stock
um
would brady have been able to
spin
gold out of the straw that was left
around last year that we saw i mean
obviously cam getting covered
and um and not uh being the same guy in
the first three weeks was a death knell
in a way but would brady have been able
to do what he's been doing for the 20
years prior
with that 2020 team right so so
because here's the reason though
because
bill belichick and nick casario couldn't
do as good a job building the patriots
as jason white did in tampa some of
that's tied to
the fact that they're drafting later
than tampa
some of that's tied to
draft picks being confiscated by the
league
some of that's tied to the patriots
going as belichick said kind of all in
to win super bowls and what they
perceive with rainies brady's waning
days but a lot of it has to do with his
bad roster management
bad selections bad free agent picks
so
no
they wouldn't have won but you can't say
they wouldn't have won
and just shrug there's a reason their
roster was bad in 2020 and it wasn't tom
brady
tom curran nbc sports boston patriots
insider and patriots talk host
on the podcast world right here on the
rich eisen show what do you think's
gonna
what's it gonna look like sunday night
because we were kind of setting the
stage there's nothing like it there's no
there's no comparison in sports it would
have been akin to jordan leaving the
bulls right away to go to the wizards
winning one and then coming back the
next year like that's the only
comparison that you could possibly make
and on top of it
um brady's gonna
definitely by maybe the end of the first
drive become the all-time passing leader
in the history of the nfl never to look
back
on drew brees is there i mean what's it
going to look like you would have also
had to have phil jackson say i don't
think he can do it anymore
i can win with pete myers
that also would have had to have been
present
go
wow
that because that is the vibe that brady
got that is the vibe that the patriots
said to him that is basically bill's
belief
look we won in new york with phil sims
and jeff haas stepler we won in
cleveland with city tester verdi we won
here with you we can find them and make
them
and that's you know so that's that's
where that that exists but
did you see game of thrones of course
watch that yeah all right
i think this could have have the
potential to look like the red wedding
[Laughter]
yikes tom oh my goodness
the lannisters send their regards
because oh
wow
we were wondering if brady's going to
want to rub it in do you think he's
going to i mean he rubbed it in last
year winning the championship what more
rubbing needs to be done does it need to
be done in the in in in front of the
whole world and in gillette like
literally that's
that's what you think it's going to be
like on sunday night
well don't you think that
beyond the vindication of winning right
that specifically bill
is the reason that brady operated and to
a degree robert craft who
you know i think that
and i
have had a good relationship with craft
and i understand his motivations in this
but he said look i'm gonna let bill make
the decision
and bill made the decision which was to
really not even engage
too much in contract negotiations the
point where brady was out the door
before the patriots even before free
agency began
so there was no free agent tour before
brady ruled out the patriots so i think
both of them brady fields he would like
to try and get some kind of
retribution against this is the only
chance where he can do it
there
and i think it would be important to him
to say this is what you didn't want
to keep for multiple years this is this
is the guy who you thought should be a
temp
um
i didn't hear you tom but
there's also and i understand the way it
ends and trust me um you know the way
that the only comparison i could make
for my own personal life is the way
things ended at espn did not go the way
that i was expecting and uh i have been
the tip of the nfl network spear for 18
straight years now
uh in many ways you know when i mic up
you know coming out of the mist as i
once told ray lewis when he was
competing against us on game day morning
you know like i come out of the mist
every single sunday at 9 00 in the
morning you know i wear it on my you
know it's part of my dna i totally
understand but i also you know know that
my seven years at espn was terrific it
helped launch my career i met my wife
there and and
you know
are we gonna forget when toe meets ball
that there was a 20-year relationship
that put six banners on the wall and
that was all born out of yes a mo lewis
hit but in that year belichick sticking
with number 12 i mean do we forget about
all of that right now because the way it
ended
i mean
does brady take his foot off the pedal i
don't think so
does brady want to take his foot off the
pedal does he want to be nostalgic yeah
and that's why i kind of equated it with
the red wedding i think that my speaking
to to mr brady last week and carrying a
region conversation with alex guerrero
and then my subsequent conversation with
alex guerrero which
they like do not ask about the patriots
they would prefer to come in with a
minimum of height where brady at least
would right
keep everything above board extremely
deferential and appreciative while not
overly so
not gilding the lily and making it sound
as if it was better than it was and then
when he gets to the field
play like his hair's on fire
i i don't think he wants anything added
to it i don't think he wants the
expectation levels
rising
about vindication or vindictiveness
so that when he extracts it
then it was okay there's a surprise so
you saying there was a phone call maybe
from tom to his dad saying dad let's
just lay off the gas a little bit and he
calls up his trainer alex guerrero and
say lay off the gas a little bit because
that definitely uh caught my attention
sitting out here in los angeles and it
was
basically cut
because i'm sad like you know what i
mean like and and uh i wasn't happy
it's what i was wondering um because
i'll tell you this the fact that they
they don't want the hype or hoping that
there's less hype that that that horse
is leaving a barn i mean like literally
that's forget it i mean there's only one
game and this week as far as you know
the national media is concerned and
you've got you've got two three and oh
teams playing each other atop the nfc
west the deepest end of the pool in week
four i mean just up the road here so
that's like why do i need my people
standing out there too waving banners
because we could down the street it's
already big enough well that was the
contention but of course that's the
nature of of what we're doing get inside
the matchup and why what the feelings
are leading into it so that's our job as
opposed to what the job of you know
making it easy and comfortable for for
tom is as much as we appreciate you know
watching him as a player in the
relationship
we have to cover the match up as the
matchup is and and there is a feeling of
that even though they don't tom would
prefer that not to be the front and
center topic tom currently fed by folks
around him right tom curran here on the
rich eisen show um so uh
what about what happened last week
obviously brady's gonna come in ornery
we know that um
mac jones looked every part of the
rookie quarterback for the first time in
three weeks i think that we've seen um
and the saints picked him apart
now here comes todd bowles and the team
that i think on behalf of brady he's
just mentioned how brady wants to keep
everything under the radar as best he
can in terms of what sort of retribution
he might be looking for in the way that
things end in new england i think the
defense might take up that mantle for
him
um on behalf of
the pa the buccaneers against mack jones
how is
mac jones performance first three weeks
how do you think he might fare against a
ferocious front seven coming for him
sunday he's still been their best player
on offense huh
so even even though the product and the
statistics look bad
it's a byproduct of the protection that
they're not giving him and it's
protection breaking down on multiple
fronts it's losing to four man fronts
it's losing to blitzes it's losing to
pressures
it's
losing
when there's blitz pick up by the
the back
um it's an inability for guys to to
uncover
you know mac jones and it's been
exhibited in the first
especially the other day but in the
first three games he does not have an
electric arm
so he's not going to throw you out of
trouble necessarily if he doesn't have
a wind-up area to throw it hard
so
until the patriots can figure out how to
keep the heat off him until guys can
separate quickly off the line of
scrimmage it's a problem now before was
okay we'll go five wide and we'll have
jim white you know motion out at the
snap he's going to be heard we'll have
him motion out
and then we'll win matchups with
amendola or edelman who are short space
separators and tom knows exactly where
they're going to be and where to throw
it it'll just be like you know eating
off their heads eight yard gain after
eight yard gain
can't do that they they're their squad
guy now with a taller longer guy who's
not as fast as those guys jacoby myers
agalor henry
and johnny smith have been kind of
disappointing through three weeks
it's gonna get better but the best
aspects of the team rich right now
offensive line the new tight ends and
the front seven defensively
have been the
weak spots and that has to be troubling
to the patriots going into this game
they're not playing like the patriots
and anytime you're backed into a corner
as the patriots
you always had tom brady to lead you out
he's not there now he's actually coming
into the corner after you
and what does belichick know about brady
i mean like in terms of
you know preparing for a quarterback
he's always spectacular at that and in
terms of preparing for a quarterback he
perhaps
knows this one more than anybody he's
ever game planned against ever
i mean i can't say the word ever enough
so what do you think he's going to dial
up here coming up on
sunday night that's a great question i
would put it this way
belichick's in the cockpit
but every time he spins a dial
the controls are not controlling the
pieces of the plane that he wants the
correct way i mean he's not asking for
alvin kamara to be left un
completely unguarded inside the five
yard line on a checkdown so we can walk
in
somebody made a mistake
so belichick can have all the game plan
ideas he wants but if those guys cannot
elevate
their level of
being on the details
brady's going to shred them they're
they're a little rudderless in the front
right now and that's steve belichick
gerard mayo and bill belichick are in
charge of the defense and right now
they're having busts they're having run
game failures
um they had 10 guys on the field the
other day rich
for the game securing touchdown run by
taysom hill
i mean
what city am i living in i know right
that's so uncharacteristic that's
there's no even words for it so before i
let you go how do you think it's going
to look with the fans 12 jerseys
everywhere he comes out of the tunnel
lfg people go crazy
uh i don't think they go crazy for him
really i think it'll be like almost like
a boxing match you know
um
in terms of you know there won't be
there'll be appreciation by most will be
plenty of people will be vocally anti
brady i think people underestimate the
number of people out here who have had
it
with tom brady tampa bay buccaneer
have had it with
alex guerrero and gronk and mr brady and
tom caron writing about him and all of
it
so there's plenty of people who who want
to see brady get his ass handed to him
but if the game starts to go badly and
for the fourth week in a row the
patriots look inept
then i wouldn't be stunned at all if
that sunday night crowd starts to turn
on the patriots themselves a little bit
well i mean because you know that's
right i mean lost amongst all this is
grunk is there too and he had quite the
exit as well that the team was not
terribly happy about in the manner in
which he he uh left and then reappeared
in tampa and
so you there'll be no acknowledgement
when he passes breeze for the all-time
mark they won't show it on the board
to see what they're going to do with
that i really would and that's what i
want to ask bill i said you know bill
you're such a historian of the game i
mean is it is it humbling to know that
tom is going to break that probably in
the first quarter
now you're asking
[Laughter]
now you're just like you're just taking
your press pass and just handing it over
to the patriots say here take it that's
i mean that's basically
i mean there must be a feeling of awe
is there
maybe that's when they'll play the the
video i don't know i mean that's
normally what happens when somebody
comes back and you we all know brady's
gonna wear a red jacket one day and have
his moment in the sun and gillette i
mean we all know those days are gonna
come but uh you know what this whole
thing
has gone as well as it possibly could
have in terms of hurt feelings
and incendiary emotions and long-term
scars
they've all handled it really pretty
friggin well
craft belichick and brady it's
unprecedented
but aside from really
you know
the peaks behind the agitation around
brady
they've high-roaded the hell out of it
and i i would imagine they're still
going to so don't you agree on that rich
they oh my god yeah i mean there's not a
lot of blood been spilled
no and and and
but you know there's going to be a press
availability for brady tomorrow and
belichick you know uh for as much as
people like to poke fun of his you know
parrying with the media and saying
nothing he's one of the most made
available coaches in all of the nfl you
know and so
there's going to be a lot of that and
and the build-up is going to be insane i
mean we're talking it on a tuesday and i
plan on talking about it every single
day i mean this is there's nothing
like this in the history of
sports america north american sports is
nothing like it
so there's no playbook for it and nobody
because like i said at some point brady
will have his red jacket so will
belichick they're gonna be in the same
bust gallery together you know um you
know robert kraft would love to be in
that gallery himself one day i mean
let's be honest everyone's gonna
eventually get together but sunday night
it's gonna be mighty awkward on occasion
yeah when it comes down to it
brady's too old
and you can't blame bill belichick for
saying look i thought he was too old
i didn't think he could do what he's
been doing he's doing it but at some
point we had to make a decision for our
future i mean that's a much easier
answer
to say philosophically we didn't feel
comfortable doing it and extending
ourselves financially and with the term
of the contract to appoint the made tom
comfortable we found an option somewhere
else yeah but that's the last thing you
want to say before brady's coming into
your house coming off a loss
you don't want to say that yeah but i
respect bill for telling the truth no no
i i hear you but maybe you say that once
tom's left the building yeah maybe
thanks for the call tom
thinking that he didn't pretending that
we wanted him to stay here when you're
like holding the door for him for five
years is cuckoo though that that's going
to agitate brady more than being honest
tom curran look for my number we'll call
you again soon certainly coming up next
week i'd love to i'd love to you know
put a fine point on this next week we'll
chat love it take care brother thanks
for having me tom carr and everybody
tom e current at tom e current on
twitter i love that guy he just mentions
no words
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here